right now despite being cleared of any
criminal conduct by the department of
homeland security inspector general
earlier in the year the biden
administration is now set to punish
border patrol agents that were falsely
accused of whipping haitian migrants in
september 2021 now remember they were
already cleared of anything illegal
according to foxnews.com these border
agents will now face punitive
administrative violations despite the
whipping allegations being totally
debunked now ask yourself if they were
cleared of any criminal conduct and if
no violation occurred
why then is there a punishment anyway
here with the latest from our border is
our very own sarah carter i think i have
some insight into that sarah and i think
it all goes back to joe biden remember
he rushed to judgment and he immediately
said
uh that those agents will pay you also
said there will be consequences well the
investigation cleared the agents so of
any wrongdoing
why is there any consequences
well sean i can tell you there's
enormous frustration there's anger low
morale here among border patrol agents
all along the u.s mexico border tonight
because of this decision
and you're right on the money this has
to do with according to the agents that
i've spoken with and people in the dhs
that are sources of mine this has to do
with president biden's statement and the
fact that he did not retract those
statements i also spoke to numerous
sources that the disciplinary action
taken by opr the office of professional
responsibility will come in the form of
basic suspensions for multiple agents
you can only imagine how they feel how
angry they are
earlier this morning we were out on an
operation with border patrol agents
where we're doing our investigation and
sure enough over 300 to 400 that's what
they were estimating early this morning
came across the border we saw people
from venezuela yesterday people from all
over the world and they were actually
part of that group of fifteen thousand
and the reason why i bring this up sean
the reason why this is so important is
because agents feel their morale is so
low right now that they feel that
they're just an extension of the drug
cartels and they're angry they're upset
and the border patrol union is going to
fight back
and the largest caravan to date it's on
making its way right now to our border
uh and i know you'll be covering it for
us sarah as always thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else